So we're here again with Paul.
Paul, why is it important to have
interactivity in your prototypes?
>> So it's important to have
interactivity in your prototypes because
one thing that I often see in demos or
in presentations is that I want
to say hey, here is my prototype.
And unfortunately,
this doesn't give you a really good
understanding of how somebody's
actually going to use your prototype.
I'm not the user,
you are not your user, right.
And so if I use this prototype,
I am an expert in it,
I know how to get good results.
If I do this.
>> I take this.
>> The person, right, and
you can actually use it and
play with it and interact with it.
You have never seen this before.
>> Right.
>> So you're going to be a much better
representation of how an end user
is actually going to use this.
>> Right.
The other thing, if there's really
nobody else around what you can do is
get really drunk and
then use your prototype and
that's going to be actually
a fairly good approximation about
some random person on the internet,
using your device or using your website.
>> Hm-mm.
>> There are actually a few different
services that you can go online and find
where you will have a usability expert
get drunk and review your usability and
send you a report on it.
>> Awesome.
Thank you Paul.
>> You're welcome.